Back roads can be found in many different places, such as
entrances to old vacant houses and gardens, scales under
fallen trees and roots,
small unused bridges and footpaths,
things like this,
telephone booths,
etc. Well, my feet usually use these special back roads as well.
No, but
why? It's
dangerous, so don't let
go of your hand,
because you don't know what will happen if you get separated. Back
roads are part of the channels of this world. We
call back roads when there are no humans,
but this place is a little special.  The
coordinates are quite distorted, so I
can take a big shortcut between the entrance and exit. That means I can
travel in a short time today.
Does that mean I can go back and forth between home and college through here? Oh yeah, other wizards.  I don't know if you
use it often,
but I think it's better to stop. We have a
contract with them, but we still
don't know what's going on. Look, the
troublesome gatekeeper smelled it and cooled it down.  We
call them hounds.Brother, you
walk by every day from the place we entered to the place we left and the place we are going.This place where you are is a waste.Here, I
have prepared a toll for you.Please,
can you please do something about
this?  It's okay as long as it's just that section. Anything
else is okay. If you
break it,
[music]
I'll chase you.